that was a Nashville and saw a
bachelorette party with their cash app
handle displayed I did the fair and
Equitable thing and requested five
dollars from them they still have not
paid
uh I think that's a great response
that's what people need to start doing
this is a big thing in Nashville I don't
know I've complained before about this I
don't know how common it is Nashville is
unfortunately the bachelorette party
capital of the world uh we get a lot of
this you know women driving around in
their cars with their cash app or venmo
or whatever proudly displayed on their
windshield panhandling if you're a woman
you CA you came with all your friends to
Nashville for a bachelorette party that
already tells you you might not be rich
but you're not impoverished if you got
the money to go to another city to party
all weekend you're not exactly a person
in need essentially you put her on your
windshield then every single person who
happens to be behind you in traffic
you're asking them for money no shame at
all